ça va être fin bien ça bien ils ont la
barbe blanche et les tempes grises des
rockurs qui auraient vieillli avec les
Pink Floyd dans l'oreeill hier soir ils
étaient là pour David guilmour le
guitariste un des leaders du groupe avec
Roger
wats c'est la guitare l'inspiration
c'est ça on dirait qu'il joue sans avoir
composé quoi que ce soit moi je le
classe plutôt dans la catégorie du rock
progressif ce rock des années 70 qui
était extrêmement musical extrêmement
symphonique
[Musique]
sur scène guilmour ne joue plus tors
cheveux au vent comme autrefis
qu'importe la voix r usé les spectateurs
voul voir une icône dans un écrin
d'architecture et pour cela certains n
pas hésité à
traverseratlantique professeur
d'architecture conna le site
de qui est à
l'intérieur la SC c'était un mélange
explosif pour qu'on puisse venir alors
on a organisé les vacances autour du
spectacle guilmour qui a emprunté à la
SNCF son jingle ne veut plus jouer dans
des stades sans âme il veut poser sa
marque sur des sites prestigieux comme
le Colisée à Rome ou les arènes de nî
les seuls désormais à la mesure de son
[Musique]
ego ça donne vraiment un ch d'entendre
c'est
les AIG c'était super ouis super super
super fan de pinkfeuille dont vraiment
vraiment tous les bons titres on s'est
acheté un petit bout de légende com on
[Musique]
dit hier soir les 19000 spectateurs
n'ont pas pris une ride ils sont juste
revenus au paradis perdu de leur
adolescence